as plots go this one is thickening by
the hour and in this pork pie coffee
shop in melton mowbry they've been
following every development
the owner nigel keep a tory voter says
customers no longer know what to make of
the pm's explanations over parties in
downing street
vaccination centers
it's been fantastic the furlough's been
great the grants have been phenomenal
he's sort of gone from hero to zero
people are not
sure whether to believe him or not
was that a moment of shame for you alan
and sheila richards were unimpressed by
the prime minister's interview where he
again apologized i can only uh and renew
my apologies both to
uh to her majesty and
uh to the country well if he took place
then he is totally out of order it's as
simple as that i always try and see the
best of people
um so it's quite difficult for me to say
that he's lying
um
but he's looking a little bit guilty
really
boris johnson is urging people to wait
for the sugray inquiry to conclude but
whatever his fate it may well be decided
in the heartlands of mary england
boris johnson it's claimed is a
politician who can reach parts of the
electorate that others cannot
but this crisis is slowly but surely
draining strength away from that
political superpower and he's becoming a
liability now
even in places like this a tory
stronghold with a fat majority people
have had enough of the chaos and the
drama
the tory leadership is launching
operation red meat to try and shore up
support with appealing policies
an operation big dog has been set in
motion to save the pm personally but
turning things around won't be easy
either
go or stay
and not carry on like this only human
there's been other people having parties
he's the leader of the country yes yeah
it's not good at all really i think it's
it's
a hard thing for him to come out now
after this
it is fair to say that support for the
prime minister has been eaten away the
question now is is what's left
substantial enough to sustain him
through what will be tough days ahead
alex rossi sky news melton mowbry